passer un été en toute sécurité voilà le
souhait de la ville de nice depuis
quelques jours des unités mobiles ont
été installés dans les gares les centres
commerciaux et les quartiers populaires
de la ville comme ici place masséna très
fréquenté pendant la période estivale
objectif proposer un test de dépistage
gratuit sans ordonnance ni rendez vous
et il y à des touristes qui arrivent il
y à l'aéroport où nous organisons
désormais aussi des tests aux arrivées
où nous devons être vigilants pour
justement qu'il n'y ait pas de nouveau
une remontée de la circulation du virus
il y à quelques tests positifs ces
derniers jours
et donc je veux que nous puissions les
contenir tout de suite dans la file
d'attenté
touristes et niçois se pressent une
simple pièce d'identité une carte vitale
suffisent en moins de deux heures une
soixantaine de tests pcr sont réalisés
puis les résultats sont envoyées par
mail sous deux jours un dispositif qui
rassure je pense que j'aime bongani siat
et pour contrôler la personne des
fusions de comité de la famille il ya ma
famille qui sont au maroc mais ici il ya
seulement des amis du coup il faut un
petit peu prendre des précautions pour
qu'on puisse les protéger aussi moi ce
sera une garantie pour un petit une
petite période parce qu'apprendre peut
toujours tomber sur quelqu'un qui est
contamine ans contaminée mais tant qu'à
faire c'est des choses qu'il faudrait
refaire presque tous les quinze jours
car la prudence reste de mise avec un
taux de reproduction du virus de 1,08
contre 1,55 la semaine dernière les
autorités sanitaires constatent une
hausse des tests positifs depuis le
déconfinement il ya quand même
un risque quand même plus élevé de
contamination et donc on voit bien que
ont repassé à les taux de contamination
important par rapport à ces derniers un
jour c'est la semaine où on avait
quasiment que des tests négatifs
là on a quand même une proportion de
tests positifs tous les jours de plus en
plus importante
cette initiative menée conjointement
avec trois laboratoires et l' agence
régionale de santé sera mené jusqu'à la
fin de l'été pour que niçois et
vacanciers puissent profiter de la
période estivale en toute sérénité